foreign
[Music]
welcome to sogcast number 21 brought to
you courtesy of Jocko willing
Productions and saw Chronicles
today we're going to turn to uh on the
ground for one of the more unique
missions during the eight-year secret
War
and this story has like two stories on
One mission
that is as we unfold here we hope you
enjoy it
we'll start with the this is in 1969 at
CCN
Lynn black was the 1-0 of RT Idaho at
that time
and it was at night in fact around
midnight
when Lynn black and his team was woken
to go for a bright light and the bright
light was a mission when a team was in
trouble
to send another team in and so Lynn
black was designated for that and he
learned that there had been a 28-man
hatchet force that had been hit while
moving toward A POW Camp this was an
American POW Camp and the mission of
that hatchet Force
was to go and to relieve find any
Americans in that camp
during the time on the ground the team
got ambushed they inflicted heavy
casualties and the mission had to be
terminated
then at that point during the efforts to
extract the survivors and rescue
helicopter had been brought down by
heavy gunfire there were at least six
men on the ground perhaps more who
needed help they needed it badly black
and his team were being asked to run a
bright light in night
and they were asked to go in ASAP also
to add to the story they were being
asked to repel in to find a team
the team that was on the ground was a
hatchet for us that this Hatchet force
was a platoon had 24 indigenous forces
soldiers that were on it and four U.S
Green Berets led by Lieutenant David
Gordon and today
we're joined by Dave Dave welcome to the
show thank you very much I'm glad to be
here well we're glad to have you this is
one of those many sock stories that um
on folds and I kind of gave it a quick
thumbnail
to set the stage for to me it was one of
those most amazing Stories uh of our of
that SOG period so this is October 69
the fact that they had Intel
on a plw camp and they sent in one
platoon your platoon to go find it and
uh just so we get down to some of the
nitty-gritty quick initially they even
put you in at the wrong location you
figured out they inserted you in the
wrong location they had to come back
pick up your 28 man for us put it down
into the correct Target area which with
that kind of helicopter activity
automatically the NBA is extra on alert
so you're on the ground and so when
you're actually in the Target you're
able to move for a day or two
and with minimal contact or anything but
you're moving towards your objective
which was the American POW Camp right so
yeah it was a suspected American POW
Camp
um it obviously the mission didn't start
out in the in in the greatest thing I
mean it did start out we were briefed we
had done our training we've done our map
Recons we weren't able to get out to
where the area was some of it have
having to do with the weather during
that time frame uh is always not the
best and that's what created some of our
problem once they insert us
we end up staying at the launch site for
a day before they could find a hole in
the clouds to just to put us in
initially and then they put us in in the
wrong location as you indicated well it
was here I am uh you know not my first
mission but I'm still a green lieutenant
and I'm on the ground trying to figure
out where I am once they put me on the
ground and and the maps just not lining
up with the terrain
just a little bit maybe but not very
much
and uh and so we're moving and I'm still
trying to line us up but I'm figuring I
know the directions were supposed to go
so I'm starting to head that somewhat
that direction
and then we ran smack dab into a uh an
abandoned base camp NBA base camp
I mean there were bunkers there were
there were Trails there were signs even
and so we moved away from that
and found a place where we could run for
the night
and try to figure out
the next day what we were going to do uh
coveyed we'd already given Covey the uh
the okay we were okay on the ground so
they were gone so we're just on our own
and so that's what started out this uh
episode you might say or two of them
indeed so
um the second day you're on the ridge
line so you're able to observe from that
Ridge line and then you're planning the
next the third day of the mission was to
move but things changed well yeah and
and actually it was two the first day we
were we set up and all night long we
could see across the distance to the to
the West we could see uh moving lights
moving on the roads and stuff from
trucks and we weren't going to try to
call in the airstrikes which probably
wouldn't have been the great idea didn't
happen uh but no there was nothing
available
and we were at max range theoretically
at the chief for the 175s and the one
seven fives were notorious for not not
hitting their targets correctly at Max
rain at max range especially when you're
on the on the gun target line so we
didn't we just spent the night uh there
we got up the next morning and moved or
started a move and Covey come in for for
a welfare check
and couldn't find us for who we were
supposed to be
so we finally vectored him in and next
thing I heard is I I wrote up in my
stories was basically oh [__]
you're not where you're supposed to be
and I says I'm where you put me and
immediately he did some you know working
with the headquarters uh with the
communications and says oh we're going
to pick you up and put you in the right
spot you're not in the right spot you're
not even on the map
and so they did that and that's what
caused as you said a lot of helicopter
work in an area where we're not you know
not normally there
um I'm sure it alerted a lot of folks
and they dropped us in and we moved all
that next that second day we moved until
we found the spot you just talked to the
one this yeah the Ridgeline where we are
on for that night and then at what point
did you get your first enemy contact we
got it early in the morning we had uh
we'd set up set up perimeters my
interpreter comes to me and says buku VC
they're there we hear them on the radios
apparently they picked up our our call
our frequency and they were talking on
our frequency and my interpreter was
very concerned about it obviously and so
was I so we set up a little extra
perimeter uh security uh and we went to
50 percent
and we got up the next morning quietly
got ourselves got everybody ready to go
set up my perimeter uh selected my point
people uh and we started out we started
on the Ridgeline and we didn't get
they didn't get 50 to maybe 75 feet and
then then they opened up on them uh with
with automatic weapons fire and RPGs
into them and into the trees above us
right and so everything was put at a
stop at that point and that was about
seven 637 in the morning no kidding so
then at that point the mission turns
from going to find an American POW Camp
where the Congress hold our people to
survival exactly uh protect what we had
try to figure out what we were going to
do get our get our security and get us
out of there we called in and there was
no break contact continue Mission we had
dead and wounded uh we had to get out of
there
so to advance into the The Narrative
where we get your personal experience
during the day you're able to get your
wounded and Kias out they're able to get
lifted out by helicopter and then at
some point you determine that the
mission is done so then you begin to
reduce the number of people from your
platoon they get distracted and then at
some point get down to the last you had
your last remaining contention you had
uh your final helicopter which was you
and the one prior to you
those were the last two helicopters on
the left the second one left it took
pretty heavy gunfire
yeah the second one we really took a
heavy gunfire
um kind of the day uh was it was a long
long day the first to get the wounded
out the serious wounded out they came in
with jungle penetrator and dropped down
and we got our our series wounded out
then we had uh
trying to figure the counts here uh one
from 28 to 24 and then we've cut an LZ
it was the next thing we were trying to
do is cut an LZ with what we had because
we were we were double triple canopy
should we cut what we could for an LZ
and then we started extractions later
late that afternoon
the first uh of the of the four
helicopters that we're going to need to
extract this all out of there came in
got away okay we're talking all ue's
here at this point these are all Huey's
at this point yeah at this point 101st
was was pulling us out and we had they
had their gun support as they as they
normally do
um
and we'd hear a little gunfire here and
there not from them but from other
so the first aircraft came in pulled out
my first group of people which was which
was my dead and wounded uh not not
serious wounded but my and the few
casualties we had
then the second one came in uh I picked
up and I put an American on each
aircraft uh with my one of my Sergeants
and it pulled out and it started pulling
away and it took gunfire and it actually
damaged the aircraft and wounded people
in the aircraft so they it went down a
ways away and so the next part of the
mission
for the support was to take care of that
aircraft get the crew and and and any of
the Wounded out and I found out through
Covey that my American had been severely
wounded with a couple of rounds in the
Torso but they took care of that so next
it was try to get us out well by then it
started getting dark
and so we needed I had 12 people left on
the ground uh myself Sergeant Schultz
and you had 10 other little people with
you and so the first helicopter came in
uh you had of the 12 you had two
Choppers are going to come in right and
you told Schultz get on a helicopter
with the Brew I'll be leaving on the
last helicopter would be me and some of
my in ditch right and so as the second
as that first of the two helicopters
lifted off where Schultz was supposed to
be on it that helicopter lifted off and
you're looking at the helicopter and as
it lists off who's standing on the other
side Sergeant Schultz are standing on
the other side
smiling at you and and I I pointed my
finger at him and I I was not hey you
could tell I wasn't happy and he goes
like this
which told me and for our listeners
you're putting your hands together which
we're together yeah fingers two fingers
together and that's saying to me we're
in this together yep side by side so he
saved he stayed back and he saved two of
the Yards right he threw two on in his
place so that left us with uh five on
the ground as opposed to six because I
had split the team up so or what we had
left so we had full throughout 360
Security right so that bird got off
that he was supposed to be on got off
okay and they I think they took some
fire as they pulled away from the area
then the second bird was coming in to
pick us up and we were trying to talk it
down because this was not a clean LZ uh
you you had enough trees and there was
danger of Blade strikes so they kind of
had to come in and jockey their way in
and they had to come straight almost
straight down go move vertically or
horizontally a little bit and then come
vertically down and to get down close
enough for us to be able to get on the
aircraft
well I was starting to talk it down in
in the pilot and right he said my crew
chief will talk me down he he'll
understand better fine he talks them
down we get down and we get to where we
get everybody on uh Sergeant Schultz had
jumped on everybody and I don't know I
had this philosophy right or wrong I was
always first in last out that just was
me well you're the team leader yeah
it's supposed to be yeah yeah absolutely
so all of a sudden the whole front Whole
World opened up the to the to the front
of the helicopter and
I just it would start he the pilot I
don't know if he did it out of instinct
or whatever he just started uh pulling
Collective and started lifting off
I jumped I literally had to jump for the
helicopter I wrapped my my left arm
around the uh there's a support hole
support pole between the door gunner and
and the crew and the in the cargo area
wrapped around there and my knees were
on the skid I I pulled myself up and put
my knees on the skin right and we were
coming out
we were lifting out and you're firing
with your car yeah I've got my car 15.
I'm firing the door Gunners are firing
I'm sure they were firing from the other
side too the other side of the aircraft
and uh we lifted out we actually cleared
the trees on the LZ and all of a sudden
we started drifting uh to the left uh as
you look at the helicopter and you know
look to the front of the helicopter and
I figured initially my thoughts were
we've taken gunfire what he's trying to
do is doing a combination of evasive uh
maneuver and
uh trying to gain speed because we were
pretty good altitude get transitional
yeah I get lift out of whatever it's
called and so I figured that drift was
okay and then all of a sudden I realized
even it was dark you could just see
enough of because of everything was
going on
we weren't just drifting and we were
going down and
um that I remember that uh well going
down I've got your note on that where
you say quickly however I realized we
were out of control and we were going
down
suddenly the main rotor hit trees on the
left side
and flipped right with such force that I
lost my grip on the pole
I was free falling backwards yes and now
it's where it gets a little dicey the
helicopter was following me crashing
through the trees
I was sure it was going to land right on
top of me
I fell far enough
that I had time to actually say to
myself David you blew it this time
that's true I remember that it was like
it's like you see in movies where you
see that slow motion oh yeah the
adrenaline
opening up before you know just just
just slow emotion as you're falling or
or anything uh and then I hit the ground
and and and I hit the ground harder than
anything ever a while I can't imagine
and then the helicopter just crashes all
around me
my first instinct right or wrong my
first instinct was to get as far away
from the helicopters I could and get
some cover because I thought you know I
didn't know was it going to catch on
fire was going to blow what was it going
to do well and just for the record that
helicopter crashed right behind you
impacting only a few feet away and to
this day you still don't know how that
helicopter missed you as you're both
falling I don't know and and the blades
didn't hit no I mean I don't know how I
didn't get hit by the air by the
aircraft so at that point you realized
you had a problem because some of your
notes on this are just so graphic
you wrote I tried to move
but my body wasn't responding
I hurt real bad all over
I need to get away from the helicopter
like you said I managed to get loose
from my rock grab my car 15 and dragged
myself into nearby brushing trees
but you're lucky the helicopter didn't
explode
I was able to find I was able to find
anything definite about your injuries
I just felt mangled
and it really hurt to breathe or even
move you know
that's when I gave myself I carried
morphine uh because I also was trained
as a medic and I and I carried the
morphine on the team
I gave myself a ceretomorphine to try to
calm myself try to see where I was going
to be
um
and then my next Instinct after
after a few you know that I was alive my
next Instinct was was to was to check on
the crew because the helicopter hadn't
exploded there was some little fires
around but I wanted to check
I want to check on my men sure so I
dragged myself and I could do a little
bit better with the morphine I got
myself back to the helicopter and in the
dark tried to because I didn't want to
turn on any lights I didn't know what
was around us and I tried my best to
check on everybody
and everybody I checked on was was gone
they were they were dead shot up
um
the pilots were I couldn't I had to
check on them from the back because that
was all shot up the whole front end was
shot up
and I didn't find anybody alive so I
crawled back to my my secure position
right and I then
got a hold of I then pulled out my
arc-10 and the survival radio which is a
small small survival radio that uh once
you you key it it just opens up the
world to for communication
there so he could respond right away
yeah so Covey responded right away uh
because they didn't know and then I told
him what I felt the situation was and
they said well where are you located and
I says well okay I'll shoot off a pen
flare so I shot off a pin flare so they
knew where I was in a relationship to
the helicopter the crash
and uh then that leads another part of
the story absolutely because you're by
yourself yeah and then you heard some
movement over time
and then I heard some movement coming
from the aircraft or somewhat in the
direction of the aircraft I heard this
movement
and uh I figured you know they're
they're searching for me the the enemy
the NVA or the VC so you turned your
radio off get your car 15 on full
automatic
and you're ready I was gonna go yeah if
that's what it was I wasn't going to go
by myself
and this voice calls out in this deep
Southern drawl
and and and the two things happen number
one I was happy to hear there was an
American alive yeah because I didn't
find anybody alive
and it was safety for him because
I see steep Southern draw told me right
then and there I had an American
or a friendly yeah not even just an
American or friendly and uh it saved his
life because I was ready to shoot it up
um and it turns out that that the door
gunner and the crew chief had managed to
survive the crash because they're kind
of
encapsulated in their back area in the
aircraft right and they they had they
had a couple of minor wounds uh from the
crash itself and they had they had
gotten away while I was trying to
recover myself they had moved to the
other side of the helicopter into the
jungle uh and when they saw the pen
flare they they realized it was you know
some help maybe or somebody else alive
so they were moving to me uh to where
the pen flare was fired from
to uh
and go back to your note too getting
into your head a little bit I was
emotionally relieved and I was
determined to get us out
I had a radio you had contact with Covey
and a way to get us home
then they told me there was another
Survivor so you were able to go back
they were able to go back and find a
brew one of your Mountain yard members
who's a member of your Hatchet Force
yeah apparently have been thrown to the
other side of the helicopter but
unfortunately had a
had a broken leg we're not sure you know
at that point I can speculate or was
told it was a femur uh from what the
medic
had described I mean what I found out
through other resources that it was
apparently a broken femur so they had to
they had to almost carry him or he had a
broken leg I think we'll just leave it
at that I had to carry him while they're
trying to help me uh
so we now needed to get out of there and
that's when they called to have uh the
helicopters come in with uh with with
strings with ropes to drop down to lift
us out of there and when weren't night
no oh yeah we were dark and also I think
you should tell us in our audience
you didn't know it then but today you
know you had how many broken vertebraes
and other what else was broken you had a
quote broken back yes that's a medically
defined broken back you're on the ground
giving yourself morphine you're gonna
give yourself a second ceret here in a
moment but
let us know what the injuries were that
you found out after you survived this
ordeal well I found out uh I found out
then uh as far as
some the injuries was I had L three four
and five and my back were crushed
um I eventually actually lost an inch in
height I have found I've had other
ancillary injuries the contusions on my
body were just unbelievable that's why I
hurt so bad all over
um and they were probably what hurt
worse at first because that was
you know realizing I didn't realize
about the back I've also found out that
I have fractures now on my upper
vertebrae that they never found out
about because they didn't really do MRIs
in that area then right so it and then
I've had surgeries due to the injuries
that have been
mostly uh Skeletor or Orthopedic
injuries that have
developed from that that actual fall
okay so but I just thought we as an
important contest because thank you
you're on the ground with a broken back
trying to do what you're just describing
here you're able to get to your Brew
working with the crew chief and the door
gunner and I think that um what is not
stated here was on that crash we lost
Sergeant Schultz yes and that's just one
of those incredible moments where he
stayed there to be with you side by side
and that crash had a tragic turn to it
and then also during that time
uh Covey because he knew exactly where
you are you're able to pinpoint your
location Covey was working air assets
yes they had spooky there covering you
uh doing uh going around enemy to
keeping the enemy busy while you're just
trying to survive there on the ground
and I think that um at that point
he calls back oh then they try to come
in one more time with a helicopter with
ropes right and one of the extraction
methods the helicopter hovers they can't
land they throw ropes down to you in
this case they threw ropes that were 100
feet long but you're in double triple
canopy and you're going through the
ordeal of being on the ground and the
ropes are not long enough no they aren't
and we tried moving to we tried moving
also to other locations where maybe they
could get closer into the trees and they
couldn't they just couldn't so now we're
talking and I think let me interrupt for
a second you're being very modest here
these two guys are picking you up with
your broken back you're in triple canopy
with a brew who's been wounded and
you're trying to move through the jungle
to get to a better height you know and
actually they were carrying them
I had found something I could use for
kind of a crutch and I was just hobbling
along morphine had finally kicked in and
I think I could move better you know you
know Better Living Through Chemistry
indeed uh so and then they we decided it
wasn't going to happen and the
helicopters were losing uh uh a time
they needed to get refueled so they'd
had to go back and and
re restring the aircraft and I think
there were huge at the first time and
we've talked about this we've been able
to come up you know decipher some of the
things that went on uh you know with the
fog of War uh but at that point when
they said they couldn't uh that's when
Lynn's team gets notified that yeah
Covey goes back and the so um uh RT
Idaho was on standby and uh they were on
standby for another mission but they
were told that they had a bright light
and just for the record of running a
bright light at night
is exponentially increased the inherent
risk normally associated with the most
dangerous Assad missions
and just for good luck the brass told
Idaho to repel into the target
when they reached the launch site Lynn
got briefed they had a medic Ron
Williams was added to the team because
they knew that you all had injured
Personnel on the ground you being the
team leader duly injured and nobody know
how knew how severe your injuries were
and with that Lynn black launched and we
learned later that the helicopter pilot
was Captain on who flew that mission and
he's one of our legendary kingb pilots
and he was uh you know they thought they
were going to be
repelling into the target so while
they're flying out they're tying the
ropes down
but um
captain on was able to maneuver the the
king bee into the LZ area near the crass
helicopter so Lynn could get his six-man
team on the ground
so was Lynn black with four indigenous
troop members and the medic
they get on the ground and um so you're
aware of them being on the ground but
when they're there they're it's dark
there is some light that comes up from
the crash site because there's still
some Burns that are going on according
to what uh what Lynn had seen at the
site so at some point
um Lynn moves through the jungle he
leaves a couple people at the helicopter
and then moves north of this of the
crass helicopter and
are you aware that they're on the ground
by now or any point does he cover or
somebody say you hey the guys are on the
ground how'd that go yes I was alerted
that they were on the ground and we were
going to try the link up and of course
that in itself even in in the best of
conditions linking up
in the middle forces in the middle of
the then then being in the middle of the
night I mean you've got everything from
the high adrenaline from being in in
combat to being dark and everything else
we somehow managed to link up without
shooting each other up and that was that
was uh that in itself was great and of
course I was I was so happy to see
Glenn and them and no one I was probably
going to get out I think I think the
first thing I did was give him a big hug
well again also you didn't know the name
of the team or anybody I didn't know
Americans coming towards you that's
right and the only thing I knew
as we were doing is I knew that the team
leader had the code name Blackjack
that's all I knew for a very very very
long time
and we uh and you John uh you have been
instrumental in us actually getting back
to you guys later you know 34 years
later uh we actually I actually be able
to meet the person with the team that
rescued me uh but that was that was uh
a really traumatic time to try to find
us and Them them me to find them uh high
intensity
again but we did it and uh thanks
everybody they got me out but uh well
here's another thing getting out wasn't
the greatest the action either oh I know
we get to that not so great action in a
few minutes but there's another angle to
this which uh I came I came back to CCN
a few days after this incident and so I
got back on Idaho and the first night
I'm there Lynn talked about this mission
and some of the things he talked about
he later wrote down and he talked about
searching for the survivors and that
there were edges of glowing pools of
light provided by the subsiding fuel and
oil fires still from the crash site
and then he was like this is like his
feelings from being on the ground
looking for you all said suddenly I
became aware of moss insects fluttering
up and about
intensifying my awareness of our
surroundings even further
so now the three of them he has his
point Man sound his counterpart and he
are moving in point and The Interpreter
point to another Direction and they're
moving away from a firefight Fire Light
into the inkiness of night
it was so dark but you guys had
fireflies which never think about and it
seemed like my contact with fireflies
and layoffs they were big suckers and
when they lit up it wasn't like the
little flyer flies in America that lit
up your hand it was really cool these
could light up you could see people's
faces off of these things yeah they're
much bigger and Lynn was experiencing
that too trying to come to you yeah and
you has a firefly exposure yeah but I
don't remember I don't remember that
part of it I think uh
my focus was on so much other things
I don't remember the fireflies but that
doesn't mean maybe that's why in some
cases we could see a little bit better
at night uh or you think you could
anyway you could see just that little
bitty area yeah I want to just go back
to his thing again just a little bit
because this is him trying to find you
in the middle layoffs in the middle of
the night enemy around Spooky's firing
Cubby's talking to both of you and and
he's on the ground and his he said the
three of us are on the undergrowth under
growth trying to dodge hovering bugs
there are bats moths at one point he was
talking and he was talking into the
radio and he had to stop because the
moth went into his mouth
and choked him and then uh then Lynn
says right he's writing about himself
stay focused concentrate blackjack
and this is what he heard an occasional
crackle from the fire snaps us to full
Readiness full automatic Readiness once
again I turn around looking in the
direction of the down Chopper loan
longer can I make it out he's that deep
into the jungle now
we cross over into the Netherworld
unseen forces tugging and pestering us
from all points on the compass
the further we make our way into this
world
our newly honed Knight senses the more
we become aware of the small eyes of
thousands of animals peering at us
between jumbles of leafy branches
and Barbed Vines snakes and small furry
nocturnal creatures scatter under each
footstep
this is like trying to work your way
through Brer rabbits Briar patches
blindfolded
and so it just goes on but that is his
side of trying to get to you then at
some point they you're able to make
contact with we were yeah
um to the grace of God we we actually
made contact without
any injuries any more injuries well and
then also who was flying Covey that
night it was one of our legendary covers
yeah writers yeah I think Pat Watkins
was flying cubby that mandolin and I and
I found out much later from Pat just the
uh the the third side of this story and
that's all of the air support all that
was going on at night at night
um yeah and uh I think he'd come in as a
relief because uh because it was such a
long mission that they had they had to
swap out Cubbies and cubby Riders
uh but he just uh he he actually was
able to add a lot to my information and
knowing what really was going on around
me because I that point was focused just
on the on the getting the four of us out
of there that was my
sure that that was where everything had
got boiled down to uh at that point
uh I do remember one at one point where
you know talking about the air support I
had left a strobe light on the on the on
the original LC because when I jumped
the aircraft I wasn't going to go back
and get a strobe light right and
apparently there was a lot of movement
after after the crash on the LZ
uh the original LZ and Covey comes up
and says is there any uh did you leave
anybody behind there's there's people in
light on the LZ and I says no
that's none of us light it up and they
did oh they did they lit it up big
um this is before the bright light came
in oh yeah this was before the bright
light this was after I was on the ground
before we this was before the fir
actually before the first attempt to
pull us out
um
so there's just a lot of little sideline
stories or that go on around this thing
that is all overnight and this is not
there there's no night vision no
infrared vision there and again it had
you not let that strobe light
they probably would not have been able
to accurately direct ground fire to
correctly or even see that there were a
lot of people on there because you know
the strobe light would put just enough
light to see that there were there was
the enemy was there they were covering
they were working over the the site
indeed and then uh looking uh just the
last time I want to go back to the
Blackjack side of this thing how they're
looking for you and they're not able to
make contact and uh he's moving
and they they thought they heard
something and then at one point
Lynn was I'm waving my hand and my
interpreter's face I get his intention
and retrieve the survival Whispering
this is Blackjack over this is Blackjack
over because he had heard somebody and
he wasn't sure and he goes Blackjack
cubby are you ready for extraction so it
was Covey who hurt him not you and so
Lynn's trying to deal with this negative
mandolin because that's a code name for
Pat Watkins stand by this is Blackjack
we're still looking for the HF survivors
the hatchet Force
Blackjack Dan
on the radio you came up according to
what Lynn wrote Blackjack we can hear
you above us
so take it from near I mean well that
that's and I had forgot now that it
happened until Lynn wrote about it yeah
um and then once we knew where each was
we could move carefully uh towards I
moved carefully towards them actually I
don't know actually I don't know that
for sure we did move and we did link up
and then and then at that point the
medic is able to work on you and the
Brew he's ready to assess us yeah there
wasn't much much work that could do on
me because nothing was there was there
was a you know some some wounds but
there was nothing sure but the but the
biggest problem was of course the Brew
in my opinion and then uh then calls in
through cubby calls in to get us out of
there they'd reached they had re uh he
strung the hill strong the helicopters
are set up new helicopters with longer
ropes yeah and then that's when that's
when the whole extraction thing started
uh with uh and then took Lynn and his
team took charge uh and and was able to
do everything and uh start to get us out
of there and uh the only thing I
remember with Lynn is that he and I had
a little bit of discussion I wanted to
send the team you know because they
could only take out two at a time uh and
I want them to take out the the two
Americans and he said no you're going
out
wouldn't have been my choice but he was
in charge and and so what you've got to
explain to us uh on your extraction we
had a
um a rig that was called The McGuire rig
right so at the end of the Rope there
was what we call the McGuire rig was was
basically a strap that was hung and it
came down about six inches wide it hung
down two three feet and then the other
side would go up and it reattached to
the Rope so it would hang there like a
large seat and then at the top of it on
the left hand side I think there was a
there was a strap or a rope that you the
people are getting distracted could put
their hand and tighten it correct which
you did that day or that night I mean
yes they they they put me in the sling
and before they lifted off before we
left off oh yeah and it was it was that
was just that was what it was it was
just a a canvas type seat that just
wrapped around your your legs and you
were
you you your right arm generally went
around and grabbed a hold of the the
Rope or the other part of the seat so
you were strapped in because it
basically came down in front of you as I
described with my hands video it came
down kind of in front of you so you
wrapped your hand around and grabbed
your harness so your the the top of the
McGuire rig was between your chest and
your arm your left arm went up and they
put it in a noose for lack of a better
term right the latted security well this
turned out to be a lifesaver for me and
the reason why that was there was just
because if somebody got shot became
unconscious or in your case when you're
finally lifting up there is gunfire at
the helicopter lifting you up and
instead of lifting you up above the
Treetops you become a human pinball in
the trees in the trees and then what
happened there as you're going up I mean
this is like a nightmare compound right
what had it to happen is it knocked me
my seat uh my butt out of the out of the
McGuire rig seat and so I'm essentially
hanging by my left arm uh and telling
myself it ain't gonna happen twice I am
not going to go through this again and
so they get they finally clear and I'm
hanging there and the medic has has gone
out uh Sergeant Williams has gone out
with he decided to put the Brew in his
lap uh the mountain yard and you two are
side by side we're potentially side by
side and I can't see this I'm right at
the point of of at some point you may
have even passing out yeah sure
I just remember hanging there and
telling myself it ain't good well it
turns out that Sergeant Williams hit the
Medicaid decided to take the Brew put
him in his lap and take him out because
he was too small to fit into the McGuire
rig and he's ready to lose him
in hitting the trees
sadly the The Brew was knocked from his
from his grip and lost him and he fell
to the ground I did not know this till
many years later I thought we the four
of us had gotten out and I found out
that the Brew didn't make it uh and
there was no attempt in any possible
attempt to rescuing him at that point
because we didn't know where we were uh
you know later in life right uh and uh
it has to be a tough thing for for
sergeant Williams to have to deal with
for all of his life he was a credible
medic yeah but so they get me they
finally I they get to an area and I
think they're low on fuel or some or
they've decided to get
get down on tarmac get me inside the
aircraft
um because one of the reasons why is
because when you have people hanging
from ropes to helicopters take more
energy they burn more fuel and if they
can find a spot they will land and
sometimes it's a rough Landing which you
have a rough landing and uh I got drug
across the tarmac I don't know how far
and then they got me into the aircraft
and got me to the hospital
and then you know all the all the little
things that went on for that too which
is all other stories
so I got bounced around pretty good that
night no kidding and then uh they were
able to extract the crew chief and the
door gunner and then Lynn was able to
get to his email and we'd come back with
some of the finite details later but for
you personally from there because part
of this whole story is like the tertiary
side of this thing is they pick you up
take you to a Medevac Hospital patch up
then you get on the hospital ship no
that's a different story that's a
different story different wound
different oh my god well take it from
there you're picked up after you get in
the helicopter they take you where well
they take me to 40th Med uh uh and they
get me in the ICU
and I'm there I'm finally starting to to
come around and the next day
you know this was at night so that next
morning
uh they're they're working on me they
don't know exactly what's what's still
what's wrong they just know that I'm I'm
I'm broken and I'm beat up so to speak
very broke and uh so I'm I guess maybe
still morphine still in me I'm decided
I'm going to get out of get out of bed
and go go to the bathroom
and and so I get thrown my legs over the
edge of the bed and I set myself up on
the engine and then and then I couldn't
move at all so the nurse comes in and
her name was Rose Nelson I remember that
uh she comes in and she looks at me she
just shakes her head so she says you get
back into bed and I says I can't I can't
move so she gets me back into bed and
and I remember she was the ICU nurse and
she came in to give me a a kind of wash
me down because we're pretty smelly at
that point and she goes to try to wash
me down and
she starts and I had I said you gotta
stop
because your hands feel like 60 grit
sandpaper I can't I can't take it
because the apparently all of the
bruising and stuff was so bad
so I'm there and then the next I don't
know if it was that day or the next day
I'm laying there and I wake up
and I oh no
there's a priest leaning over me
and I'm not even Catholic
and I thought
oh no I'm getting my last rights yeah so
it wasn't he was coming in just he was
one of our our
uh chaplains coming in to check on me
but I thought for sure in my days that I
was in my last rice and it was going to
be all over uh going through those
things so keep it right there because I
want to get back for a second yeah
because the other side uh getting back
to Lynn's side of this thing which is
the Recon team side and
um there's two points of it he had
this whole dialogue between you and him
that before you finally connected which
went on a lot longer than your side of
the story but you finally did connect
but then when you're getting pulled out
on the ropes he talks about
um
the uh as you're starting to go up
green tracers and Rockets light up the
midnight sky
so this is what the helicopter pilots
and you the survivors are witnessing
hanging for dear life
the anti-aircraft fire begins to
punctuate the moonless night the
helicopter applies full power to his
engine swinging a ride wide Arc in the
direction of safety meaning getting the
hell out of there heading back to
Vietnam
and that is the part of that I didn't
know about yeah because you're just
hanging on you're in the middle of the
Jungle being a human pinball bouncing
off of Mother Nature's trees and then uh
just before we get back to your story
um they were able to get out again that
team came out on strings and when they
got when they came back the very next
morning that Recon team had the repack
and go back to get the helicopter and
work through all that mission yeah with
no sleep and just enough food to eat and
reload and they went out and recovered
it so back to your stir which is why
we're here
um so your Medevac then after the
Sandpaper the nurse with the Sandpaper
hands on your body what's next well they
sent me to uh
Third Field Hospital in Saigon I think
it was and then from there uh they they
they put a cast on me a body cast body
cast because if they had realized they'd
done the x-rays and stuff and realized
that I had the fractures in the back
um and then uh I went to an Air Force
they send you an Air Force staging
hospital then I was medevaced from there
to Japan to the 249th in Japan spent
some time there and then uh Medevac from
there to Letterman General Hospital
which I spent about a week or so there
and they felt I was stable enough they'd
taken the cast off that I was I was put
on convalescent leave and my my parent
my mother come and picked me up with
some friends she they came she brought
up this big big Cadillac and you're
still in the body cast no I'm not I'm
out of the body cast and I just have
bracing on really I had gotten out of
the body cash and we talked to story but
yeah but you got to tell a lot oh okay I
got to we when I got to Letterman I was
not happy about
not having had a bath or anything for
for weeks and weeks this is how many
weeks after the actual at least three
weeks after the basketball Mission yeah
they tried to do the old the old
SpongeBob thing and I was not happy so
I'm laying in in the board in the bed
and and when they'd come and debriefed
me at that 40th Med uh the team the
group from uh
uh from CNC had come and did a lot of
debriefing trying to trying to get it
all put together before right before the
before they let me go so to speak sure
um they had brought my Beret so I had my
Beret with me because I didn't have it
was that Russian so I had a beret and I
carried that with me all the way through
uh it had it with me all the time indeed
and uh so I get there and I got my Beret
with me and I said I'm and I want to
take you can't take a shower you've got
a cast on you're talking to a nurse I'm
talking to a nurse and not nurse ratchet
no actually she was pretty good I didn't
get a nurse ratchet during the whole
term uh fortunately uh and and I said
I'm going to take a shower so you can't
take a shower by cancer I said I looked
at her and I said I'm going to take a
shower with or without a body cast on
and she looks at me she looks at the
Beret she says can you wait a couple of
minutes and I said just a few minutes
and next thing I know they're coming in
they're taking the body cast off you
know because I'm going to take a shower
oh yeah so I go in and I take the shower
and I it is funny parts there's funny
there's good humor in all of this so I
dropped the soap well I can't bend over
to get the soap so I ring the little
bell to get somebody help she comes in
she I says I can't get the soap up and
so she comes over picks up the soap
hands it to me and says you drop it
again I'm going to get you a prison soap
in other words a soap on the road
and so that was my that was my stay at
uh part of my stay at uh Letterman
um and you know so I stayed at Letterman
for a while and then went home and then
I was unconvalescent leave uh at home
for and where was February home was at
Roseville California uh which isn't far
it's it's it's about an hour and a half
from Letterman uh which is about how
many hours from San Fran
uh Letterman is in San Fran yeah no yeah
it is I know I remember because when I
first came in they drew they pulled they
when I met her back then which was one
of the best airplane rides I've ever had
because they knocked me out entirely
coming from Japan Japan to Travis I was
I was dead to the world you take off in
Japan
and the hot oh
and backtracking yes that happens in
going from Travis to Letterman they put
me in a helicopter
and I go I'm not sure I want to be in
this thing you know I've already been
through too much of this particularly if
it's a UE after getting shot yeah
but anyways it all went it all went well
so uh I I saw Roseville and I go and
convalescent leave until around end of
February
uh and then I go I I they figure I'm
well enough Letterman's released me off
of convalescent and I I go back to Bragg
uh and I get assigned then to uh
third group okay so let's uh take a
little break here in this storytelling
to wrap up the first story which was on
that night
you knew the code name was Blackjack
which stuck with you yes and blackjack
when I talked to him he goes yeah we
pulled these guys out on the I don't
even know who they were
but Idaho was able to get you out and
the rest of uh your the remaining team
the survivors out and uh so we fast
forward 34 years and actually it's 33
years because now oh okay
um you and I are members of the Special
Operations Association right which has
annual reunions and lost lost wages
and and not and 33 years before that you
came up to me introduced yourself
because we had our CCN shirts on and
we're talking he said you know
uh I heard I heard you've been doing
some interviews and I got a good story
you know and so I talked to you I said
well I'm working on the other things and
I'm still working full-time I got my
family but hey if I don't call you talk
to me next year
and so next year 34 years later after
that incident you came up to me and said
hey remember me I said yeah I'll never
forget your story and I said did you
ever figure out who rescued you you said
no
and I forget if you said blackjack or
not but at some point during our
discussion I said I remember Lynn
talking to me when I came back to CCN
because this story was just so
incredible one of the first if not the
well
one of if not the first night bright
lights to repel they were going to repel
in
and uh so that stuck with me I said hey
you know you got to talk to that guy
that was Lynn black yeah and you guys
met and that was the first time at the
34 years where you two were to get
together and since you become good
friends you've been to his house he's
been to you yeah your house and you guys
have celebrated time and again at the
reunions with your with your sweethearts
you know yeah
it's been and that was where I have so
much appreciation for the soar and then
of course for you uh having being the
conduit of getting us together because
you had heard both stories yeah but what
for your story being so damn incredible
I never would have remembered it
yeah and and so it's been it's been
great to have that uh that reunion and
and add another sidebar to that
I I had always regretted I was never
able to get into in touch with Sergeant
Schultz's family right and recently
within the last two years
for some reason I finally saw the wall
of the Traveling Wall
and uh Vietnam Wall in my home near my
hometown
and
somebody says have you ever looked on
the on the website for The Traveling
Wall uh because it's it's it's been
tough for me oh absolutely I mean think
about the way he you know he stayed out
a helicopter to be with you and within
minutes oh that's tragedy yeah and I
went on and found and saw where somebody
and his family
it was his niece had written something
on the website and fortunately she had
left her email address which was in
Oceanside Oceanside and there's a yeah I
forget as I talked because I remember a
little bit more well it turns out I I
wrote her and she eventually she hadn't
been looking her email eventually got
back to me and I have now been able to
hook up with Sergeant Schultz's niece
and we've done a lot of talking back and
forth and I was able to go I went down
and visited them uh a day and we sat
down and was able to talk about all of
these things and she was able to find
out for the family
more about what happened because
things weren't being told then it was
all top secrets you were only told that
something happened in Southeast Asia and
that's what they got in their letter
that you know oh yeah you're in South
Vietnam yeah and now he was injured yeah
and uh and so it was a very close
reading we've been in touch ever since
back and forth trying to get there but
then turns around you had to do that
yeah let me intersect here just for a
little quick sidebar I walked we used to
live in Oceanside California before we
moved to lovey downtown White Bluff
Tennessee
and one day I'm walking and I had a
special forces shirt on
and my special forces had just walking
along one of our streets in Oceanside
not far from my house because I always
took a daily walk this guy with a big
dog comes by we wave he sees my shirt he
goes hey
were you a Green Beret it's a long story
short at some point he goes did you ever
know a guy named Dave Gordon well
Oceanside
50 years or 51 years after you have this
credible Mission with you and Lynn with
our Recon team coming in to rescue you
you could have knocked me over with half
a feather I'm going well uh Dave Gordon
like he goes yes Sony we had that little
sidebar gave him the book with your
story in it and we had a new friendship
there until we finally moved here but we
had this is a sidebar so this is a good
point so in your life David how did you
a little guy from up there in Northern
California
decide I'm going to get into the army
your story is getting different because
you could were you drafted did you
volunteer you said I've read the Green
Berets or what was it that got you going
here well and well I was drafted I was
fighting it all away I wasn't fighting
the draft right I was trying to go to
college I was trying to go to school uh
I enjoyed the campus Union more than I
enjoyed my studies and so I wasn't
getting very good grades I know that
feeling so I I got drafted in the
original draft not even the lottery
draft is that right what year is this I
was in 67. okay January 67 you get this
California boy and it was sent to Forest
loose Fort Lewis Washington in January
so that was that was a treat all in
itself so I went through uh yes Fort
Lewis and then they decided uh I was
going to be a medic so I went to Fort
Sam Houston Texas and became a medic and
that's when I first got interested in
Special Forces because of the the
medical training the Special Forces
medical training we had a lot of the
guys that were there that I'd run into
and I would stay I was kept at Fort
Lewis or I mean sorry for Sam Houston
for a while uh to uh run troops uh they
kept me there instead of sending me to
everything and run troops well I was I
was an acting sergeant in charge of the
new AIT troops that were coming in okay
and then I and I was on standby to go to
OCS uh well that got put on hold and
they sent me to Germany
to be uh
to the 509th mechanized Airborne unit
and I wasn't even Airborne so I walk in
and I want to become airborne and first
sergeant Road first sergeant there a
great first sergeant it had two Souls of
two feet placed painted in front of his
desk and that's where you stood when you
talked to him
well he asked me he says you're not
Airborne I said no for sergeant he says
you want to go to Airborne school I said
yeah I would like to he says okay get
your stuff you're leaving tomorrow so
they sent me to Wii spot in the Airborne
to jump school so I go to jump school
and respawn really yeah
I didn't know they had one there yeah
and uh so I went to jump school there
yeah and then I came back and I was in a
medical platoon for a while and all of a
sudden I get called in
and first starting Road decided I was
going to go to NCO Academy
so they turn around and send me down to
the seventh army NCO Academy
and I'm down there and of course it
battles you also have the Special Forces
teams down there
right yeah so I come I continue to come
associated with the Special Forces
so I get back from the NCO Academy and
I've done I did fairly well there
so next thing I know I'm being called in
and they're going to send me to OCS
so I leave him go to OCS when I come OCS
you get to pick you get to put in your
preferences your preference for well I
put in my preference for infantry
Special Forces and I got it really and
so I go to Fort Bragg
after you graduate from OCS after I
graduated from OCS at the top of the
class I assume uh I don't remember that
I remember I remember we had a lot of
shenanigans that's for sure and we had
kind of a special class because most of
our classes was prior service really
they weren't brand new out of college or
brand new recruits there were a lot of
prior service we had former e7s e6s
Supply sergeants and people that were
people that were in the Mi you know and
so we have fun we had fun in that class
because people knew things and could do
things that the tax weren't ready for
yes and OCS is never the same no it
wasn't uh so I mean we invented a
candidate we actually invented a
candidate and the guys that were Mi had
background training breaking into the
safes right they broke in to the safes
at the Battalion headquarters and and
and invented this candidate and we'd
have people take tests for him and stuff
and they never could find him how did
the candidate do did he graduate he he
graduated but the sad part of it was and
we did it about the time they did some
recycling candidates coming into OCS
because they do that for people who
injured or something like that
and the sad part of it was we had some
guy's estate his tax and heard from him
later is that the next class they had a
candidate Fulton come in and this is
what we named this guy candidate oh no I
can't imagine what that poor guy went
through
oh I mean so there were some there were
some good times and I went uh uh off uh
to uh Special Forces uh officers uh
training and then was sent to Vietnam
well I wasn't there very long I did a
couple of fun stuff you know on Pisgah
and and uh things with the team I was on
I was on an A-Team uh this is back at
Brag back at Bragg training went to uh
at that time huh you're in third group
at that time no that time I was in
seventh group seventh okay yeah I was in
seventh group initially
and so we were seventh group was
involved with uh South America uh uh and
so we were doing a lot of training
involved in that and of course in the
early days in Vietnam seventh group sent
teams TDY to Vietnam yes and one of
those teams was Roger Dolan's team who
Roger was the first Medal of Honor
recipient during the Vietnam war just as
a little sidebar yeah seventh group
history but anyways you're in Sabbath
group at some point you find yourself in
Vietnam when do you landing on I landed
a numb and I adapted to be absolutely
sure which was June
excuse me of 1969
late June it was right after
uh it was right before the siege of Ben
head right and um
so we were stuck in the train actually
yeah we were stuck in the train for a
while until that that salt got settled
out
uh and and then they then they sent us
on into uh uh I had volunteered to go to
to go to command and control
so and I think I was the only one in my
group that volunteered for that uh
by then the word was out but yeah you
figured out about such a good role I'll
just go up to CCN yeah you had another
unique experience shortly after that you
were the first member of the first SOG
sniper training course yes how'd that
happen well I don't know how it happened
I show up I get assigned and uh I'm
assigned to a platoon a tune leader and
uh next thing I know I get a call saying
well we want you and and we want they
want two members of uh out of CCN to go
to uh down to sniper School along with
two members out of CCC which is the
first yes so we were the sniper school
it was the first team Mr go to snipers
yeah yeah the sniper school was put on
by the ninth division it was at the
night division sniper schools put on by
MTU mushroom training unit out of Fort
Benning so myself and so they want and
they decided they'd have one from the
hatchet force and one from Recon so
sergeant arbite from Recon
and myself went down and we went down
and we picked up the other folks on we
actually picked up the other folks in
Saigon and they sent us on into uh uh
dong Tam down in ninth division area and
we went through the school and put up
with a lot of stuff uh being special
forces from the from from the from the
night oh yeah division but that was all
right because we literally kicked their
butts in Sniper School uh out of the top
out of the top eight or ten they were
going went through the school there we
we we were in that top I was number one
Sergeant arbite was number two uh in our
class CCN stood tall oh we stood tall
and and actually uh SOG stood tall and
then and and actually this was in uh
Sergeant or saw chief saw uh General
Colonel Kavanaugh is the one that wanted
this put together so I was able to brief
him going in and brief him coming out
and uh really a perfect gentleman I mean
what a person and I was nervous as hell
here I am a young second lieutenant and
I'm briefing of you know a full Colonel
who was in charge you know that's uh
yeah because Colonel that's God to me
you know right well it was because
Colonel Kavanaugh came in in early
August of 68.
only two weeks before the disaster that
would be four when we lost 16 Green
Berets and a sapper attack and he was a
World War II vet who saw incredible
combat he had several Valor awards from
World War II but he's highly respected
and he really he really cared about the
men involved in that for you to get
briefed by him and then you come back
you're done so what was so how do you uh
debrief and that's well I just we just
talked about it we talked about
particular missions that might be
available to use snipers because you had
to carry extra equipment and and it
really had to be a specific Mission you
couldn't just walk around with a sniper
rifle hoping you'd see something and so
we talked about some of the different
missions even though I was very novice
to it right of that type of thing and I
believe that some of those missions were
actually involved uh later uh you know
when you have a point mission of some
sort because you can't just roam around
with this with a sniper rifle right
um so and what was the rifle at that
time well we used an M14 national match
for training with national match
ammunition what they did what they
purchased or had for SOG operations was
a bull barrel uh Remington 600
with the same scope system that we were
using and that's what they were going to
use for for the uh for the sniper
missions for uh
for SOG operations for the teams that
went out and we're going to do that
uh
fortunate unfortunately I never got an
opportunity to really do that because of
the missions that I had they had set me
up for
because one was a straight Recon
area recon mission and the other was the
pow try to try to find the pow that kind
of interrupted your sniper yeah sniper
service for a little while so yeah I did
so we've covered that in detail and then
um you come back you're in the Army now
you're back to uh Bragg I'm back to
Bragg healing getting better I'm
assigned as the S2 for
um
I keep going third group right oddly
enough uh time frame here because what
amazes me is
you get a broken back in October of 69.
we're now in March of 1970. my calendar
says that's about five months in a few
days and you're up back on your feet now
you're going to be S2 I mean you must
have been in pretty good shape to
rebound like that with three crust
vertebraes well actually I wanna I wanna
modify that I didn't immediately become
the S2 I actually was assigned to
administrative position in uh in a b
company
uh in the third group to uh and
and I had I had my first additional duty
assignment was really something I uh I
was assigned additional duty for a line
of duty investigation
and it turned out that the investigation
was sadly for a uh a master a
I think it was Sergeant First Class but
he was a master repeller and he was
teaching and going through classes and
they were on their repelling mission
and apparag at Bragg District brag and
they were doing their I think their
first repel
and he hooked the students up and they
jumped out on the skid to repel down out
of the Huey at about 60 feet
and he jumped out on the skid and he had
forgotten to hook himself up to the
donut and cargo and he fell a direct
fall and killed him and then I'm a
person who had gone through something
similar to that yeah in a different way
but here I am assigned to line of duty
that and it was it was not easy I can't
imagine uh but I did and and we got it
all through and everything else
uh but then I then from there I was
assigned as the S2 for third group and I
was there during
um
the Egyptian president
who was who was assassinated and we went
through a lot of that because that was
our area of responsibility sure and I
was doing briefings and things then uh
and I had an absolutely fantastic
warrant officer analyst special intel
analyst
put together some very fine information
and we pretty much predicted what was
going to happen after that when Nasser
come in and really but they were very
concerned about there being an overall
coup uh going on there and you know we
were obviously very concerned
and and in that same time frame uh we
also went through
the uh first Pan Am the first Airline
hijacking that happened it was a Pan Am
airlines and it was hijacked and it was
landed in Jordan
with a terrorist
and we were put on alert
to try to deal help deal with that
because that was our area of specialty
right and we were put in Iceland they
put a Jew lot together which was a joint
unconventional warfare assessment team
which is a small group of people to go
over and assess the situation to see
what might really be needed
and we were going civilian they gave us
official red passports
an organ shots and oh that hurt but
anyway
the day before we were ready to to fly
in as civilians uh the terrorists took
the all the hostages off the aircraft
and blew up the aircraft so we end up
not going
uh good sign bad sign the fact that we
didn't have to go and deal with it that
was okay the fact that they took the
hostages off before they blew up the
airplane it was some it was was that's
when they did things differently than
they do now right so I went through all
of those things and then
um they sent me to Russian language
School
and that was going okay but not as well
as they wanted
um so and I was wondering why I was
going to Russian language school when I
figured I was going back to Vietnam and
then I said you know I want to go back
to Vietnam so
I asked to go to Ranger school first and
then be sent back to Vietnam so I went
through Ranger school really and then
back to Vietnam and we landed at CCC in
cartoon well I kind of landed there by
by accident not by accident by intent
but the fact that I got there was was
strange I was pulled into the Repo Depot
when you go through right after you land
coming back yeah Vietnam yeah coming
back Repo Depot and they have you know
you're there for a couple of days till
they figure out what they're going to do
with you and I didn't have contacts and
brag to make sure where I was going to
go so sadly uh anyway this Colonel his
name was Colonel Carpenter I remember
that he was Lieutenant Colonel he was in
charge of the Repo Depot and he calls me
in and he says oh I see you've had
you've been in combat and you've you've
had your experiences in combat he says
but you haven't had any command time and
I says oh well that that will probably
happen
and he says well I have an opportunity
for you and I said I have four companies
here I have a D Rose company an r r
company and an incompanying company and
a headquarters company
this is okay and I sit there and I'm
listening
and he says um
I really need somebody for my D Rose
company a company commanders doesn't
give you some command time you've got
some command experience and we might be
able to deal now you're a first
lieutenant right no I'm a captain from
two silver bars yeah I've been promoted
to Captain when they and that's why I
got sent to the S2 is because uh with
the position I was in was a Lieutenant's
position when I first got back so this
is 1972.
71 I think late 71 yeah late 71 okay mid
71. so I look at it territory you
covered in yeah yeah I've covered a lot
so I look at him
and uh and he tells me all the problems
they have with the D Rose company they
got guys that come in they got to be
drug tested before they can go home
they've got you know some PTSD some
every now and then one of them some have
syphilis yeah yeah have a lot of things
and uh so they have to try to they want
to clean them up before they send them
home so they don't get to go home right
away right and uh and I said so every
now and then somebody will get a weapon
or something and kind of take over the
barracks so I looked at him I said okay
that's fine I says I have a solution it
says you do is you shoot the guy then
you treat him for his drugs and there's
a gunshot wound at the same time and
send him home a hero and you look across
the desk at me and he says I don't think
you're the guy I want for the job I said
I'm glad you see it that way now can I
go here and he could have screwed me
over something fierce but he did not he
did send me back to command to SOG yeah
and then from SOG they saw me to they
needed a a a staff officer at CCC they
decided they were going to put me back
in the field and again you landed CCC
and you have some interesting
circumstances that arise that you had to
address oh yeah there was there was a
lot of things at CCC it was a good good
operation except it was totally
different than what I was used to
because you know when you're when you're
uh was in denang we were at fob2 you're
isolated you have your own Camp here we
had a road running right through our
through the middle of the camp the
middle of the camp get off Recons on one
side The Tavern and the hatch of forces
are on the other side and and the
hospital was split by the two in the
headquarters so I was sent there as a
targeting officer which was good
um you know it it gave me a chance to
start learning staff other staff work
and and I got me more involved with the
targeting and and what was set up for
the missions and doing the briefings on
the targets so I got to learn more about
operations that way you know you know
Ashley was very good but I also got
tagged for a couple of omissions uh one
in particular
was they had had a a
ch34 go down these three four no uh
jolly green 53 see it's the 43 Air Force
jolly green had been shot down had been
shot up and had to land at a base uh
engines were shot up and it landed ended
up Landing a doctor it was one of the
launch sites for CCC at that time yes
but it was also a launch site where they
often had incoming enemy incoming every
day surrounded by mountains and and you
know so you had incoming all the time
and so they they needed to get that
aircraft out of there and they were
going to replace the engine and in the
mission the my mission was a little
different but the the operation was
going to be uh secure the aircraft
secure the area around the aircraft they
were going to fly a C-130 in with a new
engine
for the ch-53 really and so we're
securing the area and incomes a C-130
they pull this engine out of the out of
the cargo area on rollers go over take
the other engine take one of the engines
off the 53 and put that engine on and
then they did this in a matter of hours
I mean it was amazing wow but during
that time frame
well they had flown us into into doctor
with uh uh venaf uh Hughes Camby oh no
yeah these are Huey's King bees I would
never worried about these were Huey's so
this was by the vena fights yes okay
well so so half is a Vietnamese Air
Force yeah and the King bees were part
of 219 Squadron which was separate from
the conventional Vietnamese South
Vietnamese Air Force yeah
different mentality
so we're they're on the ground and I
made I had the aircraft stay on the
ground because we had a a a a heavy
platoon of of indigenous myself and a
couple Americans and we secured the area
of the Airfield and the in the and the
aircraft was still on the air the
helicopters were still on the Airfield
and they were there actually running and
they're getting calls or through their
resources that there are several via
vikong Vietcong you're coming in they're
gonna they're gonna mortal and so they
said we're going to take off we'll come
back get you I says no you're not you're
not taking off
no you're not I took a I took a yard
from each one of your montiors Mountain
yards and put one of them in each
aircraft
with a car 15 actually an M16 for them
and said if he starts to take off
shooting
they stayed they stayed until we got out
of there that was a subtle but effective
methodology that was how I did things
and and sadly something that's how I did
things as I stayed in the military which
kind of caused me some problems through
the years
so so that was that mission you know
just little things to do oh sure any
other highlights for the your second
tour Duty before we get to your third
tour well my second my second tour uh we
SOG was winding down right and so you
had
the biggest thing other than when we got
the camp rocketed and fortunately I was
on a targeting uh uh we were doing our
targets and I was down in Saigon or up
35 then and on our way back they had
more they rocketed our camp and my Hooch
was gone
so I was glad I wasn't wasn't there I
was glad I was down to Saigon or on the
way back from Saigon that morning they
rocketed uh no camp and my Hooch was
gone so I mean that's semi-exciting I
guess
um but when they they went ahead I
extended and they were they were closing
down the fobs uh I was sent to what was
called The Faint training command and it
was uh a where we would bring cambodians
uh battalions in to there were three
different sites it was Don baten
there was a Milo no
there were three sites I don't remember
right now off top of my head the three
of them but I was a Don batin which is
near Cameron Bay and there there we
would uh we would bring in Cambodian
battalions
actually 500 men 500 500 as a battalion
they were they were called mobile
battalions okay and they would show up
they would get off c-130s and majority
of them had shower shoes and sarongs
really we were responsible as the camp I
was the S3 at the camp right we were
responsible for not only outfitting them
with clothing and Equipment but training
them from Individual training to
Battalion size operations in 12 weeks 12
weeks and we would have as many as three
battalions there at different
intervals of training at a time
well so who was there who were you
training them with was there any SF
Personnel yeah they were all SF
personnel and we also had new zealanders
we were looking at joint operation with
new zealanders uh and it was a joint
operation we were in a Vietnamese
compound
uh so we dealt with the hierarchers
dealt with some of the interactions
there right uh the Vietnamese were
responsible for providing the food and
and some of the other support we were
responsible for pretty much everything
else
um and it was it was rewarding at a lot
of times but then you find like little
idiosyncratic problems such as their
feet wouldn't fit oh yes
and things American they had a thing
they called battle booster what they
were was a heavy duty tennis shoe high
top tennis shoe black uh black oh yeah
black well
the the soldiers that they brought in
the people they brought in they're
they're indigenous person they're used
to working in the rice fields and so
their feet are different than ours
they're they're they're short and
they're wide it's just I don't know if
it's you know a combination of being
Barefoot all the time right from
children well these batter boots were
built for American type people shoot
feet so the all these they would they
would cut the inner part uh put a slice
in the inner part of the top of the of
the boot so that their feet wouldn't
hurt well we had as typical uh as things
were winding down you end up with a lot
of
non-airborne Personnel in charge of
things and we had this General come in
and he was going to inspect the area him
and his staff were going to inspect what
we were doing because if somebody had
decided we needed to be inspected
and he sees these boots and he sees all
of them have been cut open and he starts
getting really upset and for some reason
you're you're they're they're ruining
the clothing we're giving them they're
not being respectful right right
so finally the corner to staff and says
look it their feet don't fit in them you
know we kind of showed them physically
you they got to do this to be
comfortable another example was they
were we were wishing them A6 machine
guns which is a an air-cooled uh 30
caliber machine gun World War II Korea
level machine gun
well these guys aren't as tall as we are
they can't reach around to get to the
trigger so they'd end up having to put
the the stock on their shoulder no to
end up firing in them well they got
upset of that they're not firing them
right I says they can't reach around but
we had a machinist who was trying to do
some cutting of the stock so that they
could reach around and finally after
showing him this he made sure we got the
right tools to be able to properly
outfit and that was just some of many
things that went on little things that
went on with that but you know they were
dedicated they cared yeah
um we had you know there were there were
political incidences that happened
within the groups
well one of the interesting things we
had to publish our training schedules
you got to publish training schedules if
you're in the military we had to publish
them in English
Vietnamese French because a lot of the
leaders only spoke French
and Cambodian
so we had to publish four trainings I
had I had a secretary
who spoke all of them and she would
write those training schedules up and
then using a mimeograph machine oh we'd
publish them
you know things like that
but my my my my future highlight of all
of that indeed was is my EXO was
now retired lieutenant general Joseph
Keith Kellogg no who was who at one
point was the national uh assistant
National Security advisor for president
Trump and then became the National
Security advisor for uh vice president
um doing the name hell why do I forget
names
our current not our current but uh
oh
see you too yeah our past vice president
yeah yeah past vice president that's a
good way to say it but anyway uh to have
him and he was a dynamic uh officer in
Excel because he kept things clean you
know he kept the staff moving he kept
things between what was going on plus he
had a multi-national force not only the
Vietnamese but the the the new
zealanders who were absolutely great I
mean they were great people
um but he kept all of that together and
ran very smooth the operation ran very
smooth and we did a fantastic job of
training and sending these we'd send
them you know they come in like I said
in sarongs and shower shoes and we'd
send them back fully fully loaded up in
combat ready to go and they go right
into combat they're in Cambodia
so you felt like you were hopefully
doing a good thing with that and then uh
I finished that last that um
that's towards extension yeah tour Duty
and I came back home and was assigned
assigned to the ninth division as the
operations officer back to the ninth
division yeah
uh they were up at Fort Lewis then yeah
uh and I was signed to a battalion uh as
a battalion S3 and then I was riffed out
of the Army and the reduction of force
me and 20 000 other captains is that
twenty thousand that was 20 000 captains
were ripped between the helicopter
Pilots Special Forces and those that
weren't uh West pointers
they always took care of their own yeah
they did take care of their own and then
I was fortunate to somebody I ran into
somebody on an airplane and he happened
to be very high up in the California
National Guard and he says once you come
down and talk to me when you get home
and he got me into the California
National Guard which was pretty tough at
the time particularly for Vietnam Vets
they didn't want them right of course
and and as a captain and then eventually
they he decided and other people decided
that I should be go back on active duty
working with the California National
Guard and so that's how I finished out
my career uh of 26 years 26 years 26
years uh in the military
wow so then from there you jump from
firefights into firefighting in San
Francisco right I mean at what age do
you volunteer to become a firefighter
and then get through the training to
become a firefighter because you were no
spring chicken then no I still am not
but uh I was 46 I was 46 years old oh my
God and um
what happened is one of the Guardsmen
that was he was actually a warrant
officers our maintenance warrant officer
uh he he knew I was getting out I was
retiring I didn't know what I was going
to do I didn't want to be a rent a cop I
didn't want to be an insurance salesman
but I had I figured I was young enough
and you know pretty much able to do
things and there's been a lot of things
that have happened
medically with me from injury to now and
Other Stories so he says once you he was
he was actually he was a captain in the
San Francisco Fire Department because
I'm stationed out of Presidio and I'm
working with this assignment with those
with those with those groups yeah and he
says uh uh why don't you why don't you
become a firefighter I said so I'm I'm
too old for that he says they're testing
uh and they're they're going to hire he
says okay and he says well first off
they can't determine on your age and I
said then I said well you know I'm a
little old I'm a little out of shape I'm
sure I can keep up with all them young
studs and studettes as it turned out to
be indeed uh he says look at I've been
around you long enough no you are in
better shape than 90 of them
and then I said well then I got all the
physical stuff the medical and the you
know Herring stuff he says we'll work on
that so I went down to take the initial
test and it was a place called Moscow
Moscone Center which is a huge
Auditorium so big that that's where they
have car shows right
and Echoes like nobody's business and
the test was one of these that they did
an old style video
and I think it was VHS video they showed
it on these screens and you're supposed
to look at the video and Mark things
down and pay attention and Mark things
down
and I walked out of there because my
hearing then was was challenged indeed
and I went well at least I learned
something I'm not going to make it here
well Mike who's a captain
he was in training group for the for the
firefighters and so he had access to see
what was coming down from the test
so out of 7 200 7 200 people that took
the test
I scored 28. no I couldn't believe it I
was how did that happen I think if you
had good hearings yeah I could maybe
it's because I couldn't hear it you know
I swagged it off yeah yeah and uh
because of things that went on it took
about three classes for me to get in and
become a firefighter and so I became a
firefighter in San Francisco Fire
Department went through their they did
their own training I had to go through
the medical
uh and that I was fortunate because I
was really good friends with
uh the commander at Oak Knoll Hospital
where I'd had uh shoulder surgery uh
about six months prior
and this is Soldier surgery based off
yeah
this was the right shoulder I'd already
had done before that because of the The
Strain and and so I had to go through
first I had to go through the uh the
physical part of it which is which was
really challenging because they do a lot
of upper body work and they do what they
call overhaul which is what you're you
got this pole and you're you're pulling
ceilings down so I was well I worked at
it I made it and then I had to go
through the medical part
and knowing I had hearing well it turned
out it was Dr uh Dr Owens a female
Deborah Owens but beforehand I knew that
I had all back I had this I had that I
had gone to my friend Oak Knoll and I
says is there any way you can give me a
hearing test
legitimately I'm not trying to and he
says yeah I'll call I'll get a hold of
my uh the the surgeon or the doctors in
charge of the hearing and they put me
through what's called a speech
determination hearing test instead of a
little beep beep beep beep right and so
they'd say words to me or sentences and
I'd have to repeat them well I showed
and I passed that so when I took my
stuff into the fire department I had a
record and as I show it it's about three
inches thick of my medical records from
from the service and I pan I panned that
to her and she goes through it and she
looks at it and in that was my hearing
test and she says well I see you past
that and she looks at me and she was a
person who would talk about the whole
person not just a little something that
might be wrong with you but the whole
person she looked and she says if you've
been through this and you want to be in
the fire department who am I to stand in
your way
so she checked me off and passed me you
know yeah yeah so there I am I'm in I'm
in in the fire department yeah I
remember you come through the reunions
and you tell us about something that
fires you've been then we're going my
God Dave yeah there's been some
interesting ones fires and incidences
you know they're not all fires you know
car accidents things like that that
but it it's uh it was it was rewarding
to do to do that kind of work everybody
wanted me to become a I said oh you got
to become an officer you ought to become
an officer and I didn't want to deal
with the politics so I stayed a base
firefighter for 17 years I wanted to be
honest just a firefighter on the street
and I turned out to be the one the
oldest rookie ever in the fire San
Francisco fire department and then I
turned out to be the oldest online
firefighter in San Francisco Fire
Department no when I finally retired
yeah
um because that's all I wanted to be but
I had the best job my last uh six years
in the department I had what I call the
best job in in the fire department sure
and that was the tiller on the truck and
for those of you don't know what the
tiller is on the truck that's the guy
that rides in the back back and steers
truck on the hook and ladder indeed and
I call it the Kramer job after the after
the uh Seinfeld episode when Kramer was
on the back of the job no is that right
love that job uh it just it just was a
great great position to be in because
you could do so much from that position
is that right yeah you you were in
charge of all the all the uh tools uh
when you had a fire you went to the roof
you went right to the roof and you
started ventilating or you know things
like that you didn't get involved with a
lot of the medical stuff because they
had the people in the front did that you
were back there to take care of ladders
and take care of tools and I was just
great not to mention getting around
tight Corners in San Francisco yeah
actually actually oddly enough we could
get around tight Corners in the ladder
truck easier than the engines could
really because we could swing it out
that's true I remember seeing that back
in Trenton when I grew up was like
that's the job I want yeah I could never
qualify for it it was a great job so
well then wait did you have brakes did
you have your own no we did not in fact
that brings up a story we go to this
this car it ended up being a car fire
and it's on one of the streets in San
Francisco that has a long slope down
towards the ocean and I'm back there we
pull up and the driver which is a
relatively new driver jumps out of the
rig to go help
well he forgot to put on the emergency
and so I'm rolling down and I've got no
way to stop this thing and it's starting
to slowly go go to pick up speed so
while I'm sitting there figuring how am
I going to stop this what's my next move
fortunately one of the experienced
firefighters saw what was happening runs
to the throws and then slams his hand on
the emergency brake as as I may have and
that stopped it right then and there of
course we go the truck almost buckles
because it gained just just enough speed
when you got a heavy trailer in behind
it but things like that you know they're
oh yeah little things like little
moments in time as a firefighters oh
yeah in the hills of San Francisco oh
yes
um but uh so I did that
and then uh and and and and I got
through the injuries uh been having my
surgeries and stuff but I also got
involved in uh only they call ultra
running indeed uh and that is as I
retired and starting in the fire
department and I got into running a 100
mile events
and I remember that and that was good it
was a good time in life it was tough it
was hard but it was a good time in life
yeah because you would run about 99 more
miles than I would
with my knees no thank you dude oh my
God but but all of this goes back to
one my upbringing
and two I think with the experience
and
teachers that I had when I was going
through school been and having really
great teachers and people who challenged
me
and then being in Special Forces
in the military I had experienced people
who took an interest in making you
better
not putting you down but making you
better yeah and having come out of the
ranks into the officer Corps I also
think it helped me listen to the ncos
uh much better right and and that really
made a big difference in in the rest of
my life of
of pushing myself sometimes in beyond my
limits but also not forgetting the
people around me
indeed and so as we get closer to
closing out here another issue that
you've had to deal with all along is the
um the the whole thing with PTSD you
know it's it's been it is is partis
driven my life and the PTSD I think
really hit of course with Sergeant
Schultz oh yeah and
and even though the gesture that he made
and what he did
impacted on me tremendously emotionally
it also impacted tremendously on me and
how I viewed life and how I viewed the
rest of my time in in the service in any
place else
and and and and pretty much what it was
is you're going to do what I tell you to
do if it's not illegal if it's not
immoral and if I'm in charge of you're
going to do it the other thing part of
that is if you do what I tell you to do
and it's right you get the credit
if you do if you don't do what I tell
you to do
and you get
get it uh you get it wrong it's your
problem
if you do what I tell you to do and you
get it wrong then that's my problem
and that's how I viewed
my both my uh military career
and actually in times that I was put in
charge of things in the fire service
and
in the PTSD
comes from I went through that I went
through more experiences in the service
not just Vietnam but also in in life
sure where I I when actually when I
first became the S3 in in the ninth
division at the Battalion I had a uh one
of my operation Sergeant was it was a
very definitely alcoholic and I had to
force him and I actually brought in and
legally had him put into a program
because he wasn't going to get better
and sadly he didn't make it but that's
the type of person he had to be had to
take care of your people even if they
didn't like it right you had to do
something for him and that's how I
treated
treated my my life and my career both in
the military and in the fire service
you've gotta you gotta take care of
those around you because they're the
ones going to take care of you
amen and uh
but the PTSD that
are always Sergeant Schultz's in my in
my mind and then the things that I saw
the things that I experienced in combat
and the things that I experienced in the
deaths and the injuries in in the fire
service I kind of like jumped from one
thing into another but I never dealt
with it
um
I dealt with it in different ways but
not really proper ways and uh and I have
to thank Pat Watkins again indeed as a
person
he sat down with me we just sit down and
talk quite a bit at sore and I actually
went to his home and I went to up to uh
Utah yeah one time we sat down and he
got in my face as early sergeant major
white kids could do indeed it's this you
we've all been there in there and you go
to the VA and you get yourself evaluated
I said I don't know I'm fine I get by I
got medical he says no now do it because
you're going to pay for it later if you
don't and he did and I went in and they
did evaluate me and I didn't
play the game I didn't try to be
something I wasn't I just told him like
I was
and and when it happened and this has
happened after my partner uh
trophy real name Paul had passed away
from cancer because I felt I failed
there too because I didn't save her
well you could I mean she was up it
doesn't matter that was my
responsibility she was she was my
responsibility at that point
but you weren't a medic
I still she still do absolutely and she
uh
she's well I'll get to that later so
finally I went in and they they've
helped me a great deal and and was not
just the private
counseling from a from a psychiatrist
but also
some of the group things I've gotten
into where you don't go in and just tell
all your bad stories you and what's all
what's wrong with you once you go and
you talk about what's going on in your
life right now hey I had this and this
kind of happened and people talk about
these shows that
there's humanistic parts of even the
PTSD and that's helped a great deal and
uh and the other thing is trying to
evaluate what I am where I what I've
done
where I've been and where I want to go
where I where I should be going and how
I should deal with other people because
that is tough for me sometimes because
they don't understand of course they
don't understand but yeah when you're in
the States you don't have a brood that
you can put into the helicopter and put
to the to the pilot says they don't fly
yeah you had to deal with it without you
have to deal in a different way and I
wasn't always diplomatic in that way but
that's it'll cost me a few marriages but
that's the way it is but uh trophy is
also very important in my life as was
Sergeant Schultz in two different ways
both of them helped save me yeah and one
of them was
she made me sit down and write
the experience
she had me sit down and write it which
we used today and which we use today
because I always talk about you think
about it but until you sit down and
write about it it doesn't really soak in
and you don't have something tangible
to go back to every now and then so
there's there's very definitely two
people uh in my adult life that have
made a huge difference for me and one
with Sergeant Schultz and and that
dedication and that loyalty and you know
you don't you don't leave anybody behind
no by themselves and two is Trilby in uh
in helping me understand and
understanding me and and being there
with me well you're doing your time with
her we could definitely see a change in
your personality all of which was better
okay look at you now yeah I know I could
actually I could actually talk
semi-intelligently you know indeed and
besides her just being uh uh a really
caring gal she was really had her act
together she did and uh it was obvious
that she had a positive impact on you
that's what she did oh and uh and it's
and I think about her every day and just
like I pretty much think about Sergeant
Schultz and and everything that I do I
think about that dedication indeed uh is
unless you've been there you don't know
no and that's what hard for most
civilians to understand
some firefighters police officers law
enforcement they can understand that
because they've had incidences where
it's been a life and death situation but
for the most part civilians Only See It
On movies and TV and stuff they don't
really understand it they don't see it
at a gut check level like you did or
like you did yeah and we had a couple
nothing like that
I never had a broken back oh how many
inches have you lost I lost almost I
lost almost an inch in height they just
recently finally after 50 years
uh two years ago they went in and did a
lumbar laminectomy because my
my hips were so were getting so bad from
from the from the cramping and the
pinching that was going on on my back
even after I was running 100 mile races
I couldn't do it anymore
um they did that uh six months six
months ago they did my left shoulder
again
um they're now they're looking at some
other things that they're trying to fix
and the VA has been absolutely fantastic
I go to Santa Rosa clinic and I go to
San Francisco uh for the operation for
all the operations and they're they're
associated with UCSF and an interesting
thing about that and if they don't mind
me just taking just a few minutes
you know and it goes back to Vietnam in
all honesty and all Oddity
um
the surgeon I went into was going to do
my back uh Dr Dang
uh went in did my interview talking to
him uh because they'd done enough things
that they kept trying to find the
problem they found the problem they were
trying to relieve the problem and
firstly they did is they gave me a
couple of epidurals in my back and they
didn't last but a couple of weeks he
knew he says there's more wrong we got
we got to do more
and they've done probably a half a dozen
MRIs on my back but we sat down and we
talked before we started the epidurals
well
his father
was a doctor in Vietnam
and he worked for the U.S forces
when we pulled out of Vietnam
the U.S forces probably the CIA maybe I
don't know pulled him and his family out
of Vietnam wow and relocated them here
in the states
well they had two sons and I hope they
had them then or you know brought with
them or they had them well
both sons became
the doctors in different ways
and both of them work UCSF and both of
them give to the VA as a thank you
wow our surgeons and both of them are
highly regarded when I'd say doctor oh
yeah yeah well it turns out
he did my back his brother did my
shoulder no yeah dang me yeah exactly I
kept it All in the Family
[Laughter]
uh it was very interesting but I mean
talk about people who give back oh yeah
you know and he told me that he says
because we spent first interview we
spent almost 40 minutes just talking
which you don't find that in a doctor
not these days no
well
that gives us a positive note to kind of
head down the final part of the trail
here any last final thoughts before we
officially close out well Fisher
closeout one I want to thank you uh and
your staff for for doing this because
and Jocko and Jocko for doing this
because it does it it enlightens a lot
of folks of what's going on
um and it helps also doing this helps
the individual
because they get to express some things
they may not have been able to express
or at least get some things out
and some of it brings back bad memories
and some of it brings back good memories
you know like getting stuck on a
hospital ship and trying to fight that
thing out you know uh it brings back
a lot even though there's some bad but
it brings back a lot of positives so
they can start and people like myself
can talk to positives and not just feel
the negatives
indeed so I thank you for that well it's
my pleasure we all thank Jocko and Echo
for the team though to back us up and
even our secret technician but uh
we got to keep something in this in this
operation secret indeed indeed to stay
top secret so it's at this point that we
thank today's military the border patrol
First Responders local law enforcement
at all the different levels to help to
keep our country country and streets in
America safe even when their efforts to
defund our police departments
we thank the men and women
who served our country in years past
Heroes like you David
Gordon who served our country for 26 28
years and then for at the San Francisco
Fire Department in ever onward
we also remember and salute the men and
the women who could not come back and
who are amongst our missing in action
today and as always we thank Jocko
willink Productions his counterpart Echo
for making these uh possible and
um
last but not least we just would say God
Bless America yes God Bless America
we're back for our post interview
review and a course of joined today
rejoined after a few episodes away from
the scene our top secret technician Tom
the Tom the terrific
uh what can I say what do you think
about that story
that's uh just yeah I know it's just
like mind-boggling just another day in
Sag it's just weird because every time
you bring someone in and I get to sit
here and since I've missed I think oh
god it feels like 10 of them I think
it's bad which is horrible uh and I
apologize for that
um
I know but it's uh every time you bring
someone in it's just one story after the
other that it's like the one-upmanship
every time you bring someone in they got
a one-up the last guy you have to make
it worse it's got to be it was this bad
I mean I Can Only Imagine
falling from that helicopter
in the middle of the night in the triple
canopy as the helicopter is falling
in the same direction
you're like do I do I reach up and grab
at it or do I just do I just let it go
you know and
um and then hitting the ground and
getting at least getting out of the way
and obviously that adrenaline kicked in
to be able to move with you know when
they're broken back can you I just
but then a link of operation probably
one of the most dangerous missions that
anyone in the military has ever faced a
you know friendly unfriendly
hands down the most dangerous operation
you can conduct and yet they did it at
night at night this is back before we
have all the aviation right tools that
are available
IR strobes and you know all the all that
stuff that they have now versus what you
had back then you're just trying to link
up with you know it reminds me of uh
in the book with uh with Doug oh the
Frenchman when he went down and Linked
UP how are we going to meet this guy in
the middle of nowhere all of a sudden
the guy just pops in you know same thing
they met him on a Hilltop yeah the CIA
didn't want to get their pants wet yep
so they had to go down they gave the uh
the explosive device to the Frenchman to
uh which was very successful yeah but
it's uh you know I look at the listening
to stories and listening to you know
that just that operation and just in
general and then you look at it 33 years
later linking up with Lynn and and
finally meeting the man who saved your
life yeah I mean how
fulfilling that had to be for him but
also think about what that did for Lynn
yeah you know Lynn black and what it
does for him is like oh you're the guy
now I have a not now I know yeah no I
know who I say yeah exactly because
otherwise it's just yeah it was crazy
but you didn't is it real because you
you don't yeah exactly so finally you
link up 33 years later I know
um I remember reading that in that book
and it's just it's incredible I mean
it's absolutely incredible just
everything you went through and then to
stay in so you get drafted yeah then you
decide hey you know what I don't want to
do this stuff let me go this route and
then okay so on SF and then you know
what I'm gonna go SOG and then hey I'm
gonna stay in for 26 years yeah who does
that I mean Anthony gets Rift yeah
he gets gets kicked out you know and
then it comes back and says I'm going to
keep doing this and then like yeah I'll
give that firefighting uh reminds me of
uh uh Jim shorten oh like okay you can
it's like I'm not quite ready yet let me
uh you know I'm gonna go to space and
maybe I'm gonna go rescue people on a
boat and they'll become a PJ for a while
I get kind of bored yeah go to Mount St
Helens yeah it's just like one thing
after the other unbelievable yeah it's
you know you guys are always Amaze
um your stories are amazing uh the
heroism that is is there is what built
and makes this country great uh
everybody biased yeah we are but at the
same point it's still it's still true
though I mean that's you think about
what that the next Generations have to
look to that's why these These sogcasts
are so good because people need to
understand what men and women did back
then what sacrifices were made and how
hard the struggles are because that you
know he shows it you know that Survivor
guilt is is real hangs it you know and
it doesn't go away my dad was diagnosed
with PTSD in 2010 and he served in
Vietnam from 64 to or in he was in the
Navy but he was in 64 to 68 and you know
he served tours down in the uh downtown
by Delta so right it's like he got
diagnosed with PTSD in 2010 suffered
with his whole life but didn't know it
he didn't know what it was yeah because
there was never uh you know until the
war's recent nobody's really
kind of really coined it and no one
really put an emphasis on it and you
guys you know a lot of those guys suffer
for so many years absolutely you can see
Dave was really lucky he was able to
connect with a really good counselor at
the VA yeah and that's what and that's
what helps it's you know the friends and
family around you the counselors you can
find and the methods that work for you
to get that out because if you're just
gonna bottle it up it's never going to
go away so I know he's proof of it
indeed and get back to we kind of
skipped over but
when Lynn black in Idaho got back to the
launch site the launch site CEOs they
said we're ready for some sleep and some
food they said we'll get some food but
gear up you're going out right now yeah
they had to go back and get they went
they went back for the helicopter and
the Marines had additional bodies to
pick up so the Marines went back they
had a secure an LZ and they took then as
in only the army they gave them a
lieutenant who is going to go along to
blow down the trees to help clear out
dlz and he took the wrong kind of
explosives but of course he that was his
assignment wow so the team sat back and
before they launched Lynn told Hep The
Interpreter go get what we need he went
to see the S4 they got the explosives
the debt cord so they could really blow
down the trees after the lieutenant
failed so let the young Lieutenant fail
and then they did it the right way
course it will did they recover everyone
that was on that site do you know yeah
that was one thing that could it kind of
got glossed over I think well yeah in
the very beginning the people killed the
initial firefight were out and then
those who the bodies that were at the
crash site they were able to get them
out they did okay good yeah I didn't I
missed that already I'm not sure but I
was just checking to see if they got
everybody out I think the answer is yes
okay and uh I will check later to
confirm that but with uh Sergeant
Schultz's name on the wall yeah which is
relative saw which which he's seen that
indicates that they did get him out okay
so uh but again the Mias have a little
extra connotation on the wall
but uh just to think about that one day
and that one Mission and in fact you
know they were going for the American A
POW Camp that the enemy had with
Americans yeah and we had Intel reports
of Bauman and
we always had standing orders that if
you have an opportunity you come across
A POW Camp
go for it yeah always and so like and
they didn't get a chance no never even
got there no probably because it got
inserted in the wrong spot
a little snafu on the insertion part you
know oops my bad yes well with that uh
any other further analysis there Welcome
Back Sir no it's always great I'm glad
I'm back and hopefully we can do a lot
more of these and I don't have to miss
as many and yeah indeed and in fact this
this week we're uh this recording is
being done November the 17th and with
this week we
we meaning Jocko willing Productions and
Echo Charles will begin posting podcasts
nice of our SOG cast
and so we're looking forward to those on
YouTube nice and um we're getting some
uh people following up wanting to get
some fan club growing here a little bit
some interest and uh
um we were down last week the third
group yeah down there for a sog
uh Heritage week which was the first and
it was fascinating just to be like when
I've been with you at fifth group yeah
the same thing at third group yeah
meeting these youngest F guys they're
sharp they're smarter than we ever wore
they're probably faster yeah just
amazing and so they go yeah we're
curious about you gray heads too you
know yeah so it's good it's good Synergy
so uh with that we close out and then um
for of interest you know
um
Jocko podcast
number
247 is an interview where we read from
Lynn Black's book oh awesome and that
book is just incredible we talked about
Lynn of course we talked about some of
the stories from across the fence and on
the ground yeah and uh
even though Lynn didn't mention that
that much in his book we covered that so
that's one more angle if anybody's
interested please feel free to go to
Jocko podcast number 247 and of course
Jocko podcast259 is captain on
yeah they're a king bee pilot yep and um
so those are the positive notes and uh
please feel free to go back to sogcast
one through twenty today being number
21. and we move forward here and again
we as always we thank all of our
firefighters service members border
patrol First Responders anybody's
helping to keep our country safe
continue to pray for it and then we
always thank our veterans
and then for those who are not able to
be here who did not return
we offer prayers for them and hope to
continue efforts to bring them home
amen airborne